last month hackers calling themselves
the impact team breached servers
belonging to Ashley madison.com a
website that touts itself as the premier
forum for cheating spouses who want
partners for infidelity the hackers
according to a document they released at
the time took issue with the site
assisting cheaters they also took issue
with what they considered to be
fraudulent business practices for $19
fee Ashley Madison offered a service
whereby the site promised to delete all
of the customers account and account
activity but the hacker said the site
lied and although the data was deleted
from the public-facing part of the site
the company retained the data on its
back-end servers the hackers made a
single demand after the breach occurred
they demanded that avid life media the
canada-based parent company of Ashley
Madison take down the Ashley Madison
site as well as another site the company
operates called established men this
site was designed to connect young
beautiful women with sugar daddies who
would support their lifestyle the
hackers deemed this essentially a
prostitution if avid life media failed
to take down the two sites the hackers
warned they would release customer data
and that's exactly what happened this
week on Tuesday they released nine point
seven gigabytes of data online the data
includes names addresses phone numbers
email addresses and usernames and
passwords for some 36 million accounts
as well as details about the sexual
preferences of account holders and the
kinds of partners they were seeking
among the emails released for about
15,000 with male and gov domains though
it's not clear if the accounts are
legitimate government email accounts or
if the people who use them to open the
Ashley Madison accounts are the real
government workers who own the accounts
the data released also contained
millions of credit card transaction
details going back to 2007 although the
data didn't include full credit card
numbers it did include names and
addresses for people who owned the cards
it's not clear how much of the data
released is valid Ashley Madison didn't
require real names and addresses for
members the members supplied bogus email
addresses and other data in some cases
but the payment card transactions would
have required real names if the buyers
used real credit cards and not prepaid
cards that offer anonymity